how to do it better with GP how to use a  tie bar the right way one pick the right  clip for the right tie if you're wearing  a narrow tie grab a short half inch bar  while a larger tie can take something  longer a half inch bar is fine but going  much wider is a serious swerve silvers  and always gold sometimes to the trick  lies in the placement not too high not  too low that's a spot a simple rule the  tie bar always falls between the third  and fourth buttons of your shirt three  the tie bar doesn't just clip on your  tongue the whole point of the thing is  to keep the tie from going crazy they'll  flip it right onto the shirt Oh  give yourself some slack lift the tie  giving it a little pop near the neck and  keeping it from dragging it down